you have been where I am right now
I'm a maid man tonight you are nobody
cool when did you get up there's no
space for mercy
hey let's go
you're making quite a name for yourself
in the art fights I used to be like you
fighter your ride is here
the mentor and his protege
You're Gonna Fill Me In gambling that
is
your name Billy who are you from Atlanta
It's a Long Way From Home
you bring all your dates here huh every
single one of them
do you have any kids a daughter just
your age
what do you do again
[Music]
the room has been paid for until the end
of the week
take care of yourself
looked like you didn't sleep last night
I made a runaway he gave her some money
put it in the hotel and now she's done I
just don't think there's anything you
can do about it
someone was good
those are some dangerous people I can't
leave her there she's 15 years old is
everything okay
is your favorite
it's a money Factory oh it's much more
than that you know what kind of world it
is out there I've seen it lived it just
like those girls and I survived
I trusted you you came here
I have nothing to do with it you have
everything to filled with it
thank you